there are new concerns this morning
about popular heartburn drugs and a
chemical linked to cancer the initial
findings last September spurred a
partial voluntary recall of zantac and
its generic versions taken by an
estimated two million Americans first on
CBS this morning dr. Jon LaPook has a
look inside the lab that has uncovered
the latest concerning findings he's been
following this story John what have you
learned
Anthony in September the FDA alerted the
public to a problem with the popular
heartburn drug ranitidine which is the
generic form of santech testing showed
that samples had unacceptable levels of
the chemical and DMA which the World
Health Organization calls a probable
human carcinogen that led to voluntary
recalls than an FDA investigation to
find out why now a team in California is
also working on an answer at Emory
Pharma in California chemist Rhonda
Jaffe has been trying to figure out why
FDA testing revealed some batches of
ranitidine had unacceptable levels of
MDMA the chemical linked to cancer now
he thinks his team may have found a clue
what we found out was MDMA is being
generated as a result of heating of
ranitidine the Jaffee's lab looked at
the effect of heat on the drug over 12
days at room temperature a standard dose
of ranitidine rose to 25 nano grams of
MDMA below the FDA daily acceptable
limit of 96 but when ranitidine was
heated to a hundred and fifty eight
degrees the level rose to a hundred and
forty two nanograms so if someone were
to keep their ranitidine zantac in their
car for example and in the middle of
summertime that product is going to get
heated up and it's going to generate
this compound so MDMA in this case john
is not an impurity in the drug it's
being formed from the drug itself the
Jaffe is concerned about possible
prolonged heat exposure during transport
from the manufacturing plant which could
be an ocean away from store shelves
he's now serving as an expert witness
for plaintiffs in litigation involving
MDMA in the Jaffee's lab submitted its
findings to the FDA last week and in a
petition ask the agency to request a
recall of all ranitidine products
require the medicine be shipped under
controlled temperatures and order
further testing to assess stability dr.
Janet Woodcock heads up Drug Evaluation
and Research at the FDA it does appear
when ranitidine is heated significantly
that there is conversion into some nd
EMA it can form however these are pretty
high temperatures so the question about
whether ranitidine would need to be kept
cold to keep it from converting is
something that still hasn't been
answered dr. Woodcock said the FDA is
still investigating why some batches of
ranitidine contained higher levels of
MDMA than others for most of these
contaminants that we're talking about
the level of MDMA or other nitros means
in there is not much more than what you
might get in your ordinary daily diet
especially if you ate a lot of meat
since the recall is voluntary the FDA
says there still may be some ranitidine
product on store shelves Santa Fe tells
CBS News testing of its brand names and
tech products is ongoing and for now it
has pulled the medication from store
shelves many companies selling generic
forms of the pill have done the same as
for the source of the NDMA dr. Woodcock
told me that the investigation is
ongoing and they're looking at a new
angle which is the possibility that
perhaps when you take a ranitidine pill
even if it's a hundred percent pure zero
and the Amana something inside your body
it gets converted into it that's the
source of heat to maybe your and enzymes
and acid and all sorts of metal bars
been on the market for a long time John
yeah do we have to worry if they've been
taking it that's the big million-dollar
question a billion dollar question right
the question people want to know is and
I've prescribed it as a
gastroenterologist for many decades are
you at increased risk of getting cancer
if you took ranitidine
that is a tough question to answer the
investigation is very vigorous and
ongoing and we're going to just have to
wait for now hold your horses and wait
for the data yeah but it struck me when
they said about trucks truckers always
say anything in your life chances are
got there at some point on a truck yeah
I'm thinking trucks can get pretty hot
jobs yeah that's the question should
there be a cold chain so that when it
comes from across the country or across
the world that has to be shipped in
refrigerator we don't know that same
truck as the ice cream that you take the
heartburn medication for in the
birthplace John thank you very much
you